grab your marshmallows and pitch a tent
we're going camping in the latest
episode of american horror stories in
this video we'll be going over episode 6
farrell breaking it down and its
connections to the greater ahs universe
so follow me to kern national park and
make sure to like and subscribe i come
out with new ahs videos every week meet
jay and his teacher wife addie who are
taking the weekend to camp with their
five-year-old son jacob you might
recognize the actor who plays jay here
having appeared previously as the
extorting contractor in stories rubber
woman part 2. he's wanting a quiet
relaxed weekend away from the city where
he's a big shot lawyer and judging by
these pov shots they're not alone this
isn't the first time camping has been a
major feature of an episode or should i
also say season season 9's 1984 was set
predominantly at camp redwood however i
couldn't find any clues to link the two
other than they're both shot in
california so chase sits up the camp and
when jacob has gone to bed he gets a
little frisky and is like something else
to ignore while i rip your clothes off
your son is right there we do get some
creepy shadows of what we'll learn are
the ferals but they don't really show up
until about halfway through the episode
the next day jay gives his son a boy
scout compass this device will later be
used to connect present day with the
past because what we're actually
watching now takes place in the year
2011 as seen by this missing persons
poster but we'll get to that in a bit
addy emerges from their little makeshift
porta-potty to find a trail of blood
leading to a mutilated deer something is
stalking these woods and it isn't human
to make matters worse jay has lost their
son in a game of hide and seek and this
becomes the driving force for the
episode where and what happened to their
son as with every episode of stories we
get a new introduction which gives off a
ton of red herrings implying it was a
bigfoot who took their child we also see
that it wasn't only jacob who went
missing but several others later on
we'll learn from cody fern's character
that over the years thousands of people
have gone missing in national parks so
10 years pass and there's still no sign
of little jacob jay's an alcoholic now
and judging by the giant cork board
filled with articles tabloids and photos
has gone off the deep end in search of
his son things for him are about to
change when a stranger knocks on his
door claiming to have seen his son this
is bob burch a hunter from the area who
says his cameras picked up a boy
matching jacob's description to top it
off bob found the compass jay gave his
son 10 years ago adding validity to his
claim bonus points if you notice that
jay still keeps around his son's
dinosaur cup we learn a little more
about what's happened to jay since we
last left him ever since his son's
disappearance no one will hire him they
think he was somehow involved with his
son's disappearance and as such he
receives constant death threats and
people even slash his tires bob tells
jay that for the low low price of ten
thousand dollars he can get him an
introduction to the cartels which run
the illegal pot farms in the back woods
where his son was spotted they've been
known for kidnapping to get what they
want but with no money jay has to go to
his now ex-addie who has also lost her
job teaching don't want a suspected
child killer as a teacher it's only when
she too sees that compass she agrees to
join them on their trip to find their
son overlooking the park bob explains
that jacob was last seen in the malvaros
an area that translates from spanish to
evil or wicked jay hasn't seen addie in
over a year and uses the opportunity to
see if she's still with a guy named rob
they split because addy can't handle
having a family again she doesn't want
to go through what she did with jacob
and as they head deeper into the force
we get a better glimpse at what's
stalking them more on that in a bit the
team makes their way to a ranger station
where we meet park ranger stan vogel
played by cody fern and is it just a
coincidence that stan is just one letter
off from satan cody has been a fan
favorite in ahs first appearing as the
devil himself michael langdon in season
8's apocalypse and gay porn star turned
aerobics instructor in season 9's 1984.
this is the first time we've seen him
use his australian accent in the ahs
universe seeing as he is from australia
as jay and addie open up to him about
the real reasons of their travel stan
tells them he was working there the
night of jacob's disappearance he saw
giant bigfoot type prince and witnessed
a glimpse of a giant creature taking
their boy into the woods bob is the
voice of reason here there's no such
thing as bigfoot and then they come
across a group of dead bodies which
triggers bob and as jay and addy demand
where their son is he breaks down and
tells them it was all a scam that photo
it was of his nephew that compass
something he found at salvation army and
dirtied up to look old he was gonna take
their ten thousand dollars and turn them
into the pot growers who would dispose
of them and take their credit cards and
now that jay and addie know his secret
he has to kill them shooting jay in the
gut right before he's bitten by one of
those ferals who comes alive jay and
addy run back to the ranger station
where they hold themselves up and jay
isn't too happy with stan stan tells
them that the creatures out there aren't
bigfoot in australia they're called yaoi
which is a term for unidentified
human-like creatures resembling apes we
then learn the real reason for national
parks existing not to protect nature but
to contain a group of vicious sub-humans
called the ferals no one knows where
they actually came from but theories
arrange that they're the descendants of
mountain men or even soldiers who fled
the confederate army after they lost the
war regardless the government chooses to
keep this top secret for two reasons one
so that people don't panic and two
because these parks generate hundreds of
millions of dollars a year stan goes on
to tell them that the day jacob was
taken a group of army rangers came in
and cleared out a bunch of ferals which
seems to be protocol once someone goes
missing he goes off to get some help
from the radio while addie and jay patch
up their relationship he's sorry for
everything that happened to them
realizing he was the one at fault i
wanted you to blame me i wanted to
punish myself so i destroyed the best
thing i ever had
us but just as things seem to be getting
better for the two this station is
attacked by ferals stan is ripped apart
which addie and jay take advantage of by
fleeing into the forest of course their
escape is short-lived when they're
surrounded and shocked to find their son
now 10 years older is the king of the
pharaohs even with his own throne of
skull and bones when addy and jacob
recognize him as their son jacob merely
says boo a call back to their game of
hide and seek 10 years ago i thought it
was pretty cool that we even get a line
of dialogue in their own feral language
when one of them asks what to do with
them and in traditional ahs fashion the
couple is eaten alive as their son
watches on not a lot of crazy
connections in this episode and not as
strong as last week's bow but i might
write this one as my second favorite so
far nothing entirely groundbreaking or
new here if you're familiar with films
like the hills of eyes or wrong turn you
can give us something like that but add
an element that makes it different next
week's episode is called game over and
is about a couple that spends a night in
one of the most infamous haunted houses
so it looks like we'll be going back to
murder house before season 10 of ahs
double feature arrives thanks for
watching everyone make sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember daddy loves you very much